It: Chapter Two has been screened for select
critics, and while there's still an embargo
on formal reviews, many of them have taken
to Twitter to give their hot takes.
So far, reactions are mixed, but most observers
agreed on two things: the film is wildly ambitious,
and features an amazing performance from Bill
Hader.
The movie and its predecessor, 2017's smash
hit It: Chapter One, are adapted from Stephen
King's masterful 1986 novel.
The first film followed a group of young outcasts
who dub themselves "The Losers' Club" facing
off with an ancient, shape-shifting, evil
entity appearing most often in the guise of
Pennywise, the Dancing Clown.
It: Chapter Two focuses on the Losers' Club
as successful adults who are all called back
to the small town of Derry, Maine, when "It"
emerges from Its slumber eager for a rematch.
Initial critical reactions mostly praised
the flick's ambition in tackling one of King's
most dense, challenging works, and largely
pulling it off.
One Collider horror editor wrote,
"[IT Chapter Two] is big and ambitious and
can't quite handle the weight of its aspirations,
but it's still a fine piece of heartfelt horror.
The parts that work, work REALLY well and
Bill Hader is every-bit the scene-stealing
standout we all hoped he'd be."
Hader — who plays the motor-mouthed Richie,
portrayed as a child by Stranger Things' Finn
Wolfhard — was the cast member most consistently
singled out for praise.
The Saturday Night Live alum and star of the
HBO's dark comedy series Barry has never taken
on a role in a horror project before, and
by all accounts, he absolutely kills it in
this one.
Fandango managing editor Erik Davis was also
among the chorus of voices singing Hader's
praises, writing in part,
"[IT Chapter Two] plays heavier in tone, dealing
[with] defeating the burden of childhood trauma,
[and] I definitely teared up at the very end.
Bill Hader steals it."
Even those critics who weren't particularly
impressed with the film were quick to lavish
praise on Hader, with CinemaBlend's Sean O'Connell
offering up pretty much the highest compliment
that could be paid.
He wrote,
"So, [IT Chapter Two]: it's [very] good, but
not great.
I liked it, but didn't LOVE it.
First movie is a tough act to follow.
TWO is gruesome, strange but rarely scary.
Nails important aspects from the book, but
feels overlong.
Cast is aces, though, [and] Bill Hader SHOULD
be in Oscar convo."
Of course, there were some critics who simply
panned the film.
Critic Scott Menzel wrote,
"It: Chapter Two is the biggest disappointment
of the year.
A dull [and] bloated mess that spends too
much time rehashing things from the first
film.
While there are a few good moments, the film
ultimately lacks suspense and scares.
The performances are also a mixed bag."
Uproxx senior entertainment writer Mike Ryan
had a different gripe, and although it's apparent
he's not the biggest fan of the novel, he
should probably take that up with Stephen
King.
He wrote,
"I am not an IT expert but I get the sense,
even in the book, IT's powers/motivations
aren't always well defined.
That vagueness works with the kids, but I
wish this one had some basic rules?
Because it feels like IT could kill any of
these people at anytime and just doesn't."
For the most part, though, critics acknowledged
that the one-two punch of the It movies constitutes
a feat that very few filmmakers have been
able to pull off over the last few decades
or so a very successful King adaptation, one
that sports a deep knowledge of and affinity
for the Master's writing style.
Fans will have to wait for the actual reviews
to come rolling in before they can get a more
detailed analysis of the flick's strengths
and weaknesses.
But, two things seem certain: It: Chapter
Two swings for the fences, and Hader is the
film's MVP.
In addition to Hader, the movie's impressive
cast includes James McAvoy , Isaiah Mustafa,
Jessica Chastain, James Ransone, and, of course,
Bill Skarsgård.
“haha.”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.